[Musik]
wir erleben eine zeitenwende
und das bedeutet die welt danach
ist nicht mehr dieselbe wie die welt
davor
im kern geht es um die frage ob macht
das recht brechen darf ob wir es putin
gestatten die uhren zurückzudrehen in
die zeit der großmächte des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts oder ob wir die kraft
aufbringen kriegstreibern wie putin
grenzen zu setzen
bundeskanzler olaf scholz bemerkenswerte
worte in einer historischen rede die an
den fundamentalen wechsel in
deutschlands sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik einleiten wird und
damit ihnen allen willkommen zu einem
weiteren bewegten nachrichten tag einem
tag an dem in der ukraine weiter
erbittert gekämpft wird es die
ankündigung von friedensgesprächen
gegeben hat aber der russische präsident
zugleich seine atomstreitkräfte in
alarmbereitschaft versetzt und wie diese
drohung einzuordnen ist dazu später mehr
zuerst zur wirklich bedeutsamen
bundestags sondersitzung die deutschland
verändern wird die bundesregierung will
jetzt 100 milliarden euro in aufrüstung
investieren und dies in zukunft auch
fortsetzen olaf scholz sprach davon
kriegstreibern wie putin grenzen zu
setzen und kündigte an europas frieden
und freiheit entschlossen verteidigen zu
wollen klaus brodbeck der
ukrainische botschafter auf der
ehrentribüne die begrüßung für ihn zeigt
wie betroffen sie sind stehend
applaudieren regierung und alle
fraktionen außer ganz rechts dem mann
dessen land putins truppen gerade
überfallen putin wurde den kontinent
spalten warnt der kanzler in seiner
regierungserklärung das verdiene eine
klare antwort der freien welt sie wissen
haben wir gestern entschieden dass
deutschland der ukraine waffen zur
verteidigung des landes liefern wird
wir schneiden russische bank und
staatsunternehmen von der finanzierung
haben wir verhindern den export von
zukunfts technologie nach russland
wir nehmen die oligarchen und ihre
geldanlagen in der eu ins visier hinzu
kommen die strafmaßnahmen gegen putin
und personen denn seinem direkten umfeld
und wir schließen wichtige russische
banken von banken kommunikationsnetz
swift aus es ist eine kehrtwende
deutsche politik das preisschild dieses
krieges gegen unschuldige menschen oder
bruch mit der charta der vereinten
nationen wird für das system putin und
tragbar seien diese sanktionen werden
negative auswirkungen auch auf uns haben
aber wir sind bereit diese negativen
auswirkungen zu tragen denn sie sind der
preis der freiheit
die energiewende soll beschleunigt zu
flüssiggas terminals errichtet speicher
kapazitäten ausgebaut deutschland von
russischen lieferungen weniger abhängig
werden putins angriffskrieg schließt
hier die reihen der oppositionsführer
verspricht der koalition unterstützung
sie wissen dass wir sehr darum bemüht
sind mit ihnen und den sie tragenden
koalitionsfraktionen einen gemeinsamen
weg in dieser zeit einer großen
herausforderung zu geben 100 milliarden
euro soll die bundeswehr in den nächsten
jahren zusätzliche halten bessere
ausstattung schulden für den frieden
putins attacke ändert alles
gleich in die politische analyse mit
theo koll in berlin theo das war eine
denkwürdige bundestagssitzung wie die
würden sie beschreiben was heute
passiert ist also da ist heute die
deutsche politik vom hinterher humpeln
in einen sprint gewechselt und hat sich
quasi selbst überholt gestern war
deutschland noch isoliert der
zurückhaltung weil es verstanden hat die
bundesregierung am abend in letzter
minute die kurve bekommen und heute
wurde mit einem schlag eine
jahrzehntealte politik abgeräumt
deutschland wird künftig das zwei
prozent ziel bei den
verteidigungsausgaben einhalten und zwar
nicht einmalig sondern jahr für ja das
ist lange versprochen aber nie gehalten
worden es gab eine kleine politische
erfahrung manche umstrittenen maßnahmen
können nur von den parteien durchgesetzt
werden die sie immer besonders abgelehnt
haben und die eigentlich für andere
stehen hartz4 war auch so ein beispiel
also die heute vielfach beschworenen
zeitenwende macht ihrem namen alle ehre
danke für die analyse theo koll nach
berlin die ukraine ist uns zeitlich eine
stunde voraus dort also jetzt kurz nach
8 bei vielen steigt die angst nach
sonnenuntergang weil die angriffe eben
häufiger am abend und in der nacht
erfolgen auch am vierten tag schwere
explosionen und gefechten
die kämpfe konzentrieren sich neben kiew
auch auf den nordosten des landes thomas
garcia berichtet
aktiv kriegsgerät am kinderspielplatz
twitter bilder nicht vollständig
verifizierbar zu sehen sind russische
soldaten verdammt sagt der firmen sie
schießen auf häuser
doch sie stoßen auf gegenwehr das soll
dieser aufnahmen zeigen ukrainische
soldaten die putins armee wieder aus der
zweitgrößten stadt der ukraine heraus
treiben zurück bleiben hier zerstörte
russische aufklärungs fahrzeuge charkiw
so angaben des regionalgouverneurs ist
wieder unter ukrainischer kontrolle kiew
die hauptstadt wird weiter verteidigt so
heißt es auch dort nicht weit vom kern
der metropole immer wieder explosionen
ein krieg vor der haustür viele menschen
zu gern all ist in alina riehm of ska
flüchten in u bahn schächte
ich bin mit meiner familie zu verwandten
gezogen
näher an der u-bahn wohnen und dort kann
man schnell runter rennen um sich zu
verstecken wenn bombardiert wird
wohnhäuser hier im osten werden
getroffen und wichtige infrastruktur
eine gaspipeline in flammen ein öl depot
um all das zu stoppen nun eine
zusicherung des ukrainischen präsidenten
russische und ukrainische delegation
werden sich an der grenze treffen und
zwar ohne vorbedingungen
allerdings fügt er hinzu verspreche er
sich nicht viel davon
mut machen sich die ukraine indem sie
helfen an vielen orten sammeln sie
lebensmittel und kleidung für die
menschen an der front
alles wird gut solange wir uns
gegenseitig helfen brauchen wir keine
angst zu haben
und sie tun auch das in einer turnhalle
basteln sie tarnnetze für die ausrüstung
ihrer angehörigen der soldaten die ihr
land verteidigen
katrin eigendorf sie westlich von care
für uns kathrin tag 4 des krieges wie
steht es um den durchhaltewillen der
ukraine
die stimmung hier wird zunehmend
angespannter die leute engagieren sich
zwar wie wir das im beitrag gesehen
haben dafür wirklich ihre armee hier
rückhalt zu geben aber wir sehen eben
auch dass sich immer mehr menschen hier
zu sogenannten volksmedizin
zusammenschließen und auch hier in der
gegend gratulieren um die menschen zu
kontrollieren sie haben große angst
davor dass hier russische saboteure
unterwegs sein sollten wir selber
mussten uns jetzt hier in die hotelhalle
unseres hotels zurückziehen weil sie
auch uns daran hindert haben hier weiter
zu berichten auch uns haben sie
verdächtig dass wir möglicherweise
russische spione seien könnten dass
unsere kamera lichter vielleicht
flugzeugen orientierung geben könnten
das ist unter militärischen
gesichtspunkten nicht ganz
nachvollziehbar aber das sind eben
einfache männer die sich hier wirklich
zu milizen zusammengeschlossen haben um
ihr land zu sichern
wir haben das gerade im einspieler
gesehen wie muss man diese meldung über
friedensgespräche mit russland
einschätzen denen die ukraine heute
zustimmte
gut das ist natürlich ein weg für den
sich präsident selensky immer eingesetzt
hat er ja wiederholt an präsident putin
appelliert sich an den verhandlungstisch
zu setzen und eine friedenslösung zu
finden er hat aber auch sehr klar in
richtung russland immer wieder
kommuniziert dass eine verhandlung mit
russland keine kapitalnot kapitulation
bedeuten darf sondern dass frieden im
prinzip nur zustande kommen kann wenn
russland das selbstbestimmungsrecht der
ukraine anerkennt da sind die beiden
seiten sicherlich noch sehr weit
auseinander aber zumindest ist das eine
perspektive denn bisher haben die russen
ist ja konsequent abgelehnt mit der
gewählten regierung in kiew zu
verhandeln das heißt das ist schon eine
option die hier nochmal etwas hoffnung
schafft danke in die ukraine katrin
eigendorf und wir gehen direkt weiter
nach moskau und zwar zu früh begann für
über die meldung dass russland am
nachmittag seine atomstreitkräfte in
alarmbereitschaft setzte das hat
international sorgen ausgelöst wie es
dieser schritt postdienst zu verstehen
ja ich sehe darin schon die nächste
eskalationsstufe erstens aufgrund der
art der waffensysteme die präsident
putin jetzt rhetorisch ins spiel
gebracht hat atom und hyperschall waffen
und zweitens weil er in seiner
begründung für diesen schritt ja weit
über den krieg in der ukraine hinaus
geht er sagt es handele sich um eine
antwort auf aggressive worte die
russland erreicht haben aus nato-ländern
er stellt russland also wieder einmal
als vom westen bedrohtes land da das
sich verteidigen muss und das hat ja
schon als begründung als eine der
begründung dafür gedient in die ukraine
einzumarschieren jetzt also die als
rechtfertigung dafür der nato offen mit
atomwaffen zu gründen zu tun womöglich
steckt dahinter dass moskau sich erhofft
so durch diese abschreckung einen keil
in die entschlossenheit der nato treiben
zu können womöglich ist es so dass
präsident putin heute das gefühl hatte
stärke demonstrieren zu müssen an dem
tag an dem russland das erste mal
zugegeben hat das verluste im krieg mit
der ukraine zu verzeichnen hat aber das
sind nur zwei von wirklich sehr vielen
denkbaren erklärungsversuchen danke nach
moskau für begann vier tage lang führt
russland jetzt krieg gegen die ukraine
auch heute folgt dazu bei uns direkt ein
zdf spezial alle entwicklung außerdem in
unserem live blog auf zdf heute
beziehungsweise in unserer app
frauen kinder und ältere männer immer
mehr ukraine fliehen vor dem krieg die
meisten versuchen sich innerhalb des
landes in sicherheit zu bringen viele
strömen aber auch in richtung westen
etwa 370.000 menschen haben es
inzwischen aus der ukraine heraus
geschafft dass wir schätzen die
vereinten nationen auch an der grenze in
der slowakei füllen sich die
flüchtlingslager wir uns jetzt britta
hilpert zeit
angekommen nach tagen der flucht und
vielen stunden warten an der grenze es
ist erschöpfung und toure erleichterung
die sich da bahn bricht nach den ersten
bomben auf tier haben die elena und ihr
sohn mischa die stadt verlassen nach
zwei tagen ohne schlaf sind sie nun im
auffanglager im slowakischen
ich weiß von einigen babys dort nun im
untergrund geboren wurden
heute kam die slowakische präsidentin
caputo war und brachten hilfsgüter und
moralische unterstützung und 30.000
menschen sind bisher in die slowakei
geflohen
ist es da ein großer test für unsere
solidarität und menschlichkeit
im auffanglager bieten privatleute
kostenlosen transportmöglichkeiten noch
ist die hilfsbereitschaft groß doch es
ist klar es werden noch viel mehr
pflichten
anastassia wartet hier auf verwandte aus
nikolajew das wird gerade bombardiert
sie versteht die russen vor allem putin
nicht wir lieben doch eigentlich
einander bei den genossen ist da oben
doch etwas nicht in ordnung
es ist ein steter strom der da über die
grenze kommt eine atempause ist es hier
für die meisten sie wollen weiter den
westen
wegen des russland ukraine krieges
tagten heute sowohl die eu innen als
auch die eu-außenminister gehen wir nach
brüssel zu einem gellinek eine was ist
heute dabei rausgekommen
bei den innenministern ging es darum wie
man ukrainischen flüchtlingen wie wir
gerade gesehen haben möglichst
unbürokratisch helfen kann und darf man
hier in brüssel eine alte richtlinie
ausgegraben die man nach dem jugoslawien
konflikt beschlossen hatte und nach der
können flüchtlinge in allen eu ländern
für ein jahr ohne asylverfahren leben
und arbeiten interessante randnotiz auch
die länder die sich bisher geweigert
hatten flüchtlinge aufzunehmen und die
jetzt nachbarn der ukraine sind haben
unterstützung für diese richtlinie
kundgetan bei den außenministern geht es
um weitere sanktionen einmal will man
den gesamten europäischen luftraum für
russische flugzeuge schließen für
staatliche und private zweitens will man
die sendelizenzen für die russischen
sender rtp und sputnik auch europaweit
aussetzen man will das tun weil man
findet weil man glaubt dass diese sender
den propagandistischen weg bereiten für
putins krieg und als letzte massnahme
will man nimmt man wieder belarus in den
blick als helfershelfer für den krieg in
der ukraine und verschärft auch hier die
wirtschaftssanktionen also die
spannungen zwischen europa und russland
nehmen weiter zu danke für die neuigkeit
nach brüssel an
hilfe und unterstützung für die
betroffenen kriegsgebiet die läuft über
das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
es leistet humanitäre hilfe unter
anderem mit notunterkünften bietet
lebensmittel für binnenflüchtlinge die
ihr zuhause verloren haben falls sie
spenden können können sie das tun nur
dem stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
weitere infos spenden punkt zdf.de oder
auf der zdf textseite
weltweit wird der russland ukraine krieg
die menschen auf und wie sehr das zeigte
sich heute auch in berlin dort wurde
eine friedensdemonstration für rund
20.000 menschen angemeldet gekommen sind
über 100.000 die veranstalter die
sprechen sogar von 500.000 die bilder
und reaktionen von der größten deutschen
friedensdemo seit vielen jahren hat
henriette de maizière
mir frieden peace unter dem motto stoppt
den krieg frieden für die ukraine und
ganz europa haben sich heute an
verschiedenen orten berlins die menschen
versammelt ein bündnis aus
gewerkschaften kirchen und
friedensgruppen hatte zu einer
kundgebung an der siegessäule aufgerufen
die breite der zivilgesellschaft hat
gesagt dieser völkerrechtswidrige
angriffskrieg muss sofort aufhören und
wir müssen jetzt wirklich konsequenzen
daraus ziehen wir müssen diskutieren
über den importstopp für kohle öl und
gas wir dürfen nicht länger in
abhängigkeit verseuchen despoten sein
die menschen hier sie wollen ihrer sorge
ausdruck verleihen solidarisch sein
warum zeichen zu setzen die die symbolik
folgen gegen den verbrecherischen
angriffskrieg der russischen
imperialisten und dann total überrascht
eigentlich ich habe keine tränen mehr
ich habe die ganzen augen ausgeweint
meine ganze familie ist da meine mutter
ist da die ganze verwandtschaft sind in
der ganzen ukraine zerstört
der dämon mächtigen wunsch ausdruck zu
geben dass der krieg wieder aufhört und
dass wir nicht in einen noch schlimmeren
krieg rhein gestürzt werden wir werden
wahrscheinlich putin und sagen sie was
sie damit jetzt nicht aufwecken und wenn
wir können zeichnen unsere politik sind
wir können auch ein zeichen an die welt
senden es war ein großer tag der
solidarität mit der ukraine von
tausenden menschen auf die straße
gebracht der wunsch nach frieden eine
forderung die bis vor wenigen tagen doch
noch so selbstverständlich hin
und wir schauen jetzt noch fix auf das
wetter für morgen nach einer frostigen
nacht geht's am tag mit viel sonne und
wenig wolken weiter bei einem kühlen
östlichen wind werden zwei bis zwölf
grad erreicht von uns war es dass wir
sagen danke über die situation in der
ukraine erhalten wir sie im zdf den
ganzen abend auf dem laufenden ab 21 uhr
45 im ort journal mit christian sievers
anschließend auch bei maybrit illner und
jetzt in einem weiteren zdf spezial und
zwar mit antje pieper